I'm pleased to have on the Rich Eisen
show phone line the author of Yogi a
life behind the mask oh man I mean you
want to talk nostalgia this is what
we're this is what it's all about
certainly when you need to go on and go
back to a time when baseball was in fact
the national pastime from sea to shining
sea the again the author of a life
behind the mask yogi a life behind the
mask John peso joining me here on the
rich guys and show how are you John good
how are you I'm doing fine I give you
the floor and what this books about and
why we all need it right now man okay
you know when I started out doing this
book I wanted to I thought I was looking
for a subject that would put a smile on
people's face and kind of uplift the
soul cuz you know yogi that is false
like everyone else but he was in a
sparkling figure and and everyone loved
him and I never thought I was going to
release a book into this sort of
environment but may I tell you I'm you
know just talking about it has been good
for the soul you know it and and let's
get into a little bit more in a second
we met a long time ago didn't we John I
mean you were the founding editor of
ESPN The Magazine was one of the
founding editors we met longtime you
know you were ESPN Denton and we it took
us 40 years to get that magazine off the
ground believe it or not but it was a
big success for a long time so that was
a lot of fun it sure was
I remember the opening night party John
you remember that well I mean just who
was on Chris who was on the cover of
next write it with the front Kobe Kobe
Eric Lindros Kordell Stewart and a rod
right no you didn't I mean that was the
old that was the opening cover of
everything yeah where we were all
pegging who was next you know and
obviously Kobe being being being one
that you definitely didn't miss on none
of them did okay so so get into what
your what did you learn about Yogi Berra
through this book John the three big
things and a whole bunch of little
things just some really quick little
ones he was a right-handed hitter and
his brothers who really kind of opened
the door for him and were good players
themselves but their father wouldn't let
them played and had to go to work
through the depression
convince them that is you're gonna play
pro ball this is what he's like eight
nine years old
you're gonna play pro ball left-handed
hitters make have a better chance so we
just switch sides I mean that kind that
kind of tips you off to what kind of
athleticism he had and looking at him
you would never believe that but the big
things really was how much his career he
was a dominant dominant player in the
fifties was overshadowed by his persona
and you know and just who he was a guy
who's quoted more in Bartlett's than any
president I say on the field chatty as
all hell but you get on you see him off
the field quiet to the point of almost
being shy that really surprised me and
then how much discrimination and abuse
yogi met with you know right into the
80s that I you know I had a inkling but
I couldn't believe how overwhelming it
was so there's really the three big
things that I learned he was what five
seven yogi yeah five seven and a half
you know he stood up completely straight
right 180 though of solid muscle and you
know most people think of yogi in the
last 25 years he was so ubiquitous and
you know we saw her my me up stage Aflac
duck who does that and but and you know
little guy never would imagine they was
athlete when he was young he you know
torso of a guy six two trunk of a got
you know legs of a guy who's five seven
four five four didn't look like an
athlete which is why Branch Rickey
passed on him but an incredible at the
really strong super quick great arm
fast which is that was another thing I
learned he just had everything and John
Pesa the the author of yogi a life a
life behind the mask right here on the
Rich Eisen show and then just grow I
grew up in Staten Island in New York
City John and so yogi was ubiquitous I
mean he was absolutely everywhere and
then you know obviously a a guy who took
the Mets to the World Series as a
manager which was really weird
yeah and for Yankee
I mean there's just no other way to put
it just weird that he would be not with
the Yankees and then obviously I am in
doing the research I came across a
picture that just stopped me in my
tracks it was yeah Carmen is beautiful
wife for 65 years
and yogi sitting in a chair and they
were both in Mets uniforms we're I mean
it's just I know it's just I I know and
and and then obviously coming back to
the Yankees and then his relationship
with Steinbrenner was was one fraught
with a ton I'm wondering what in this
book about that John oh you know and I
think I'm really sorry sometimes you
start putting things together when you
talk so much about your book but you
know as I said yogi endured a lifetime
of verbal abuse and amazing that he came
out not resentful but appreciative of
everyone's role in the world and you
know so the way Steinbrenner fired him
and the way he treated people in general
offended yogi was a way he treated yogi
that that was it and the thing he loved
the most when he looked in the mirror
she saw pinstripes and to walk away from
that team was a huge deal for him I mean
he always you know even in exile
self-imposed he thought of himself as a
Yankee but you know the the the
animosity on his part which he wasn't
like that normally just kept growing as
the years went by and then they made up
George apologized and it was a sincere
apology they became best friends
I mean yogi could hold a grudge but when
it was over it was over
well it ain't over till it's over right
all right until until the fat lady sings
you know so um yeah I do remember when
he came back it was just I don't know
why I was just it just Ana again
yogi played before I was born I just
knew what he meant I knew who he was I
was a big Rizzuto fan because he did the
Yankee games and I know that they were
tight but when he came back it meant so
much to me
IIIi don't know why I meant so much to
me but it really did when he came back
and then was back in the fold
you know well you know baseball and
I really miss baseball I mean it's been
in my life since I was four years old
right I think baseball fans are are
unique because I mean they're it's not
to be blasphemous but baseball is almost
religion it's just part of the fabric
and you know and here's the guy who's
walking history he's and in 1948 buck
his then marriage of Bucky Harris before
he's fired said predicted that yogi
would be the most popular Yankee ever
and you know on the Mount Rushmore of
Yankees you know is Ruth and Gehrig and
DiMaggio and mantle although I might put
yoga had a mantle at this point but
those are for and but yogi was the most
beloved and it was true in 48 and it was
true to the day he died hey well I mean
if you want to talk about winners I mean
you know we talk about Bill Russell in
the NBA you got to talk about yogi right
that's that the amazing thing I mean
this guy I mean 10 10 World Series time
I used to tease Jeter who had five and
that's a huge accomplishment but it's
not ten and and in 49 to 53 they win
five straight World Series no one no one
ever did it no one's probably ever going
to do it again and he was the best
player on that team and that's something
I think people just completely
overlooked about Yogi Berra I know I did
I mean it's the tail end of DiMaggio's
career he was hurt and older we retired
at 36 and you know bone spurs and all
sorts of injuries Mantle struck out an
awful lot and was booed like crazy which
drove him crazy in in this and since 51
into until he hits a triple crown 56
those five years in those five straight
championships Yogi Bear is the dominant
player on the dominant team in baseball
history and by the way caught the only
perfect game in the history of the World
Series too I mean I that that's amazing
is a funny little story
yogi when Branch Rickey decided not to
sign yogi played American Legion ball
for two years first time he was ever a
st. Louis sword saw the country saw how
good he was and the the team happened to
win that season and they're they're
priceless to come to New York City and
they sat
with all the Yankees before the city
started and Yogi you know st. Louis tie
they're the team from st. Louis and he
said he points over at Larsen who had I
think he was so you know like 11 and six
in the season and says see that guy
changes wind up he's going to do
something special and who knew how
special that was that's amazing last
question for you John Paso again your
book yogi alive behind the mask is
available we're all books are sold it's
a yeah the covers beautiful and the
pictures in solder are just a great
stroll down memory lane in the story and
the storytelling is remarkable thank you
of course what what do you think is
gonna happen this summer I mean I just
talked about the the the report from USA
TODAY's Bob Nightingale yesterday that
baseball thinks it's it's possible to
quarantine everybody get enough testing
and then split everybody up into ten
different divisions East Central and
West regardless of league I and and go
play some baseball maybe one hundred
hundred and ten games what do you think
of that idea
same thing I'm hearing be I'll take
anything I just want there to be
baseball I think you know what yeah
obviously life is different I live on
Long Island we're at the epicenter here
life is very different so baseball has a
different format and we just get to see
the players eager to see the changes the
Yankees made and other teams made right
I'd love it they do seem determined to
do something and I'm glad they are
hopefully they can do it and be safe
because this isn't fun so hopefully they
can do it safely and it would be great
to have baseball back John thanks again
for the time Congrats on the book and I
hope you sell a ton I hope you get the
stories out great thanks so much
right back at you that's John Pesa his
book of life behind the mask about Yogi
Berra available we're all books are sold
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here